tis the season may your days be merry  and bright happy holidays everybody copy  all these guys I hope it's fun Mary and  filled with joy don't play too hot enjoy  this precious time with your loved ones  I hope at the time away from work is a  time for everyone to rejuvenate make  sure you're with the people that you  love and take care of them Happy  Holidays Happy Holidays to everybody  Merry Christmas Happy Hanukkah happy  Kwanzaa a trauma lots of love to you and  your family have a wonderful holiday  season and a fantastic 20 happy holidays  from all of us at the academy I made  that up it was like an original line if  you want a copy writing again I've known  it's just haven't